I'm not sure the first time Shane Irving
called in I do know he's the first guest
who's ever been suspended a first caller
that's ever been suspend and I think we
sat him down for a week or so for a
language detrimental to the show and
this is anger issues as well but Shaye
would move around and different cities
and all of a sudden we find out that
he's in our backyard and I said well we
should bring in Shaye and have him do
some some predictions here so shape
joining us now Shay it's a great time
here in the man cave there yeah you too
part-timer I we did have to blur out
your feet you said you didn't want to be
on camera okay is there legal like can
you help us here here's my biggest fear
Dan let's say I'm getting into some
extracurriculars okay and somebody knows
what I look like and they spot me and
then there's a witness to things that I
do they can leverage that against me I
won't be able to get away with as much
how tall are you about six four okay
hair looks good great who'd if you were
gonna let people have an image of who
you look like
who are you told you look like like a
person yeah yes yes a person like to say
oh you look like some big dude with the
beard I know it would be a little more
descriptive I don't know Danny I mean
you're like a famous person yeah it was
a big dude with a beard oh that uh what
about the Tim Allen sidekick on a
home-improvement what's his name Wilson
no no no not the fence guy the dude in
the show with him Oh what was his name
Oh al out his buddy Alex yeah yeah yeah
that's right yeah there's a bigger al
house less flannel how long have you
been calling in the show it's gotta be
close to 10 years Danny has to be and it
was always cowboys that you were all in
well that's because of the New York bias
that is apparent in the show and that is
not true it's absolutely true that's why
I start calling in because we never had
a focus on anything going outside of the
three-state Metro wherever the heck you
I'll call it up here was a tri-state
area man who cares damn it there's a
whole lot of folks outside of that
we love Los Angeles we're morning drives
and I'll still elites Danny you know
better than that
well here we go but don't you think the
cowboy fans like you having an
overinflated worth I mean you haven't
done anything Danny
what have you done if you go me in here
just to insult me you just insulted me
and us well yeah but that was
I told how many beers did you have
before you came on four okay I'm gonna
go
is that gonna influence your picks no no
well yeah well here's my issue it's meat
day here yes meat day yeah and there's I
Polly said Polly said you can't have a
beer until you're done with your segment
if you're gonna have some meat I break
the rules Danny okay well and that's
what we love about you now we figured
since you're close by are you gonna be
close by permanently or is this are you
passing through
what are the odds of you being around
the country in different locations and
then you end up in our backyard weird me
out too
don't get me wrong oh no no not as much
as it weirded us out
yes Paulie what's the electronic thing
on his ankle over there that is personal
yeah yeah yeah all right so each week we
thought as long as you're still in a
free man yes yeah that you could give us
your five-star pics okay yeah and I
don't want you you don't have to go with
the popular games I want you to go with
what you think you'll make money on
because we're gonna keep tabs of this on
our website no this is trouble this is
trouble do we have some music for Jay
like a theme song oh we've got a theme
song yet all right here we go
[Music]
J and Irving what do you want to start
college football it's it I don't look at
NFL lines until Sunday
oh except I mean I got a couple of mine
but I'm a looksie work oh yeah I need
you to be a little bit more proactive
you're not you know the Cowboys should
always be well they are they went to
four I don't want to talk about that
right now Danny talk with the Cowboys
okay hold it okay we'll go back to
college give me your your five star
picks all right South Bama plus twenty
eight and a half little reaction from
okie light and it's traveling on a short
week Iowa State Cyclones plus three
always take the points in that matchup
BCU minus 3 like owe you plus 7 and a
half and hit plus 21 and a half against
uh you know knit me do you think oh oh
you will win no okay
the camp I think okie lights taking a
bit well well they should be good there
yeah but a lot of the preseason by the
way that's Oklahoma State that a lot of
preseason publications thought that they
could be in the playoffs nope
I think they're gonna beat oh you all
right the Cowboys and the Giants on
Sunday night with Ezekiel Elliott there
we don't know about Odell Beckham jr.
you're not touching oh you know I'll be
all over and one way or the other
but right now yeah at for ya know - for
ya Vincent's a Giants the only team last
year that really held on I mean they
swept the Cowboys beautifully
yep and they held on to Zeke for this
first game even though he wasn't the
same running back after week two yada
yada but that defense is legitimate that
secondary is legitimate here's my fear
the ginger let's he's gonna get out
coached by McAdoo that's just what's
gonna happen because if they shut down
the run he's gonna have dak airing it
out and that secondary is legitimate
Collins
to Norris they got a legitimate
secondary and Dec might get just it
might just throw it out
Collins is great is legitimate yeah they
have a that defense probably second-best
to uh to Seattle if did you do prop bets
over under 11 and a half for the Cowboys
yeah under yeah me yeah under
that too ridiculous a Rita reset the got
him at ten games max problem is they all
got film on dad and it seeks out for six
Oh Alfred Morris and Darren McFadden
good luck brother
good luck give us an idea of what you
bet on games how much well what's a
normal bet a bean is $100 yeah that's a
little bit if I'm winning it goes up
dramatic have you gone up to a gun
that's one down in the book right now
bro what happens how does alcohol affect
your gambling that's the live betting
interview we're like a Hawaii game like
a missed Saturday night and the
Longhorns lose and I'm just taking a
deep dive and I'm starting to live bet
Hawaii versus Cal you know I'm in an
issue and none of these bets if y'all
are putting the mortgage on these bets I
mean god bless you you should but get
ready entertainment purposes only yeah
that's all man you're gonna make people
some money this year they ride right
Yeah right Santa Claus is real Danny is
life good yeah that's all right yeah you
seem like you're good Fairfield County
it's like a Hallmark card I don't know
how good you got it
it took me ten days to hear my first
police siren and they I stopped dead in
my tracks I was like what in the hell
was that was it for you no oh my god
that was the other reason I stopped dead
this gotta be for me all right Shannon
arming as long as he's not incarcerated
is gonna stop buying each week with his
picks we're gonna black his face out
every week yes all right yeah nobody
knows I don't look like okay good let's
keep it that way I don't need some kind
of nerd pulling a plug and making me uh
no no no I'm not gonna do that
speaking of where is the nerd he's don't
make it seem working today
yeah yeah tell parole I still need a
standing apology for beasts marching my
wife's honored what yellow Oh dad yeah
you're gonna need to apologize because
after the cameras turn off it's a
free-for-all brother how about how about
we go to break we can turn the cameras
on for a little while and then you can
discuss that with uh mclubbe there's no
discussion to any it's an apology but I
thought yeah that's right the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience